hot breath what did you learn in
the writing structure and character
development within writing a spy novel
that could translate into comedy writing
i i had to take a lot of self negative
talk kind of off
my brain like every time i'd sit down i
would go i don't i don't know how to
write a spy book
i'm not i can't if you know if you're
dating me you'll see my texts are
horrible
i don't know sentence structure you know
i've done stand up
for 33 years i don't know i've never
made it
i've never done a set list i never
understood like i looked at people with
their notebooks and their
in their set list and and i go man i
wish i had a set list this is this is
what all the cool people are doing
i've never had a set list i've never um
i do most of my writing on stage oh
interesting so but i i mean not to swing
background i kind of have a thing
reason why i don't have a set list um
but so when i would sit down to try to
write the novel i would just get in my
head going i don't know what i'm doing
this is too hard i should and then i'm
checking amazon for crossbows and
all that stuff so what i would do is a
very fake it till you make it thing
where i would sit down and wear comics
so you have imaginations and you've had
a million
play conversations in your head or in
your shower with people and then that's
how what you know bits turn into i would
sit down
and pretend i was a guy writing a spy
thriller
i was a character who writing a spot i
literally separated myself
from myself by one by one thing
and i just sat down and go what would a
spy writer do and he sit down and
it was like so it was a dark sunday and
i heard a knockout
and i didn't get two in my head of like
well
this isn't how jon heffern talks or
whatever
so i did that yeah yeah so that kind of
got over that hurdle
of just getting out of my own way you
know
and then there's a lot of fat and a lot
of horribleness and then from there i
had the
you know chopped it down and then and
got an editor
you know to do all some of the heavy
lifting